in this video i want to get see if we
can understand the idea of a hedge fund
a little bit better and these tend to be
pretty mysterious and sometimes get a
bad name because some hedge funds do do
some fairly strange things and and
secretive things in the market so people
are are
rightfully so suspicious of many of them
but the real difference between a hedge
fund and the types of mutual funds that
we just talked about are that they're
not regulated by the sec
not regulated
not regulated by sec and because they
are not regulated they can't market
themselves
they can't market that's why when you
watch when you watch financial shows or
you get a magazine a finance magazine
you will not see ads for hedge funds the
mutual funds are all over the place
marketing them left and right hedge
funds the most the largest hedge funds
in the world are
are
definitely not even household names no
one very few people even know what the
what those largest hedge funds in the
world are and that's because they can't
market themselves no matter how good of
a of a track record or really how
reasonable of a fund they might be some
might not be reasonable some are they
can't market themselves
and they also can't take money from the
public
can't
take
money
from
the public
so in general in order to invest in a
hedge fund you have to be an accredited
investor which means you have a certain
net worth or maybe you have a certain
income or maybe by virtue of your
education you can prove that you have a
certain level of sophistication to
invest in these things that aren't
regulated you you i guess don't need the
sec to to watch your back and the so so
the regulation is a key difference
marketing no money from the public and
then the other key difference is how the
managers tend to be uh incented i know
in incentives not a word or motivated in
the mutual fund world managers get a
percent of assets so for a mutual fund
manager larger is better the more under
management the more money the mutual
fund manager is going to make so they
really just want to keep marketing and
marketing marketing it they don't get a
cut of the profit so really there's not
a lot of incentive to to try to make
kind of really beat the market here
because if they if they kind of don't
beat the market one year then all of a
sudden they're you know
their fund will shrink so they really
just get a fee on the size of the fund
and a hedge fund and usually the
implication is that a hedge fund will be
more actively managed they'll get a
larger management fee so usually so
larger
larger management fee
management fee instead of the uh one
percent one percent is actually a lot
for a mutual fund instead of that hedge
funds tend to be one to two percent so
one to two percent management fee and
sometimes even larger than that but the
even i guess bigger difference and this
is where hedge funds are very different
from a traditional mutual fund is that
the management company the general
partner gets a percentage of the profits
so a hedge fund manager or the
management company the tent the going
rate tends to be about twenty percent
twenty percent of the profits
of the profits of the funds sometimes
it's less
sometimes it's a lot more some very
successful hedge funds get twenty five
thirty percent or even a larger
percentage of the profits so with that
out of the way in the next video i'm
going to do a slight some different
mechanics of essentially the same
returns but one by a hedge fund and then
one by a traditional mutual fund